so we told DC what they should be doing
and taking from them comic books we're
gonna do the flip from so a little while
back I have Ryan and Paul who isn't here
on to talk about stories characters
concepts from DC Comics that the DC
movies should be adapting I thought
about doing something similar to Marvel
except we all kind of feel that Marvel
is so far doing pretty solid with this
stuff they don't need our advice so
instead we're gonna tell them the stuff
that they should not be putting in their
movies we both have some things I think
I mostly am coming at this for the
concepts that I don't want them to bring
in I think you're coming at it with more
characters mostly I've got a few bigger
concepts nothing specific story based
but kind of ideas and most of the idea
ones have been more recent revelations
than that yeah but a lot of characters
that I think they shouldn't maybe not
yeah okay well some of my things kind of
feed into each other so one I'd kick us
off
the first thing I'm gonna lump two
things together please do not introduce
clones or life model decoys neither of
these things should be in there clone
should be for the obvious reason because
it's confusing and pointless and doesn't
add anything and it becomes an easy way
to cheat out of death which is the same
reason that you shouldn't have the life
model decoys which is it is a lame cheap
way out of death and Marvel already has
a problem with fake out deaths for
characters which suck
somebody needs to die in infinity war
I'm not saying Who I I'm not even gonna
say I don't care I probably will if they
do it right but somebody needs to die
and stay dead I think it should be
Quicksilver again they do breathe they
should they should clone him and then
bring his body back and just shoot it
but my point is they've already got this
as a problem the last thing they need is
another way to skip out and cheat out
and avoid having to actually have death
and have consequences because I clones
are something that are iffy in general I
personally feel and I think if you open
the door to clones then you you've
basically signaled to Sony that they can
do the Clone Saga and dear god help us
all
I was actually hoping that that's what
spider-man homecoming - oh God but the
light I always hated the life model
decoys are they in agents of shield yes
ok now people will bring this up because
they have been in something they're like
oh but they already introduced this in
the agents of shield I don't care
because the TV shows and the movies do
not meaningly crossover and they won't
until either Kevin Feige or Ike
Perlmutter is out of their positions
those two men will not work together so
anything that happens in ages of shield
does not set a precedent for what they
will actually do in the movies so yes
like model decoys were introduced there
doesn't matter doesn't count I'm pretty
sure one of the other things I'm gonna
bring up was technically already
introducing the ages of shield but it
doesn't matter we're talking about the
movies specifically yeah but I've always
hated this concept this idea that
there's something that is so amazingly
convincingly human but it just exists so
we can kill it and make characters seem
like they're dead like to the point that
they they killed Nick Fury one time and
like went out of their way to be like no
this is not a life model decoy it's
really dead and then later decided to
wreck on a bike no it was an even more
advanced life model decoy than we've had
before I hate those things I hate him so
much I actually like the idea of the
life model decoy when it's just specific
to Nick Fury when he's like the only one
who gets that his his answer to getting
out of anything is get out of death free
card and his answer of immortality it's
just always got these endless like life
model decoys but for the purposes of the
movie or the movie universe I agree they
serve no purpose maybe they confuse the
issues of death and things like that and
yeah especially when the movies despite
the fact that they've been around for 10
years now and we're gonna be seeing xx
movie in this series five months from
now these are still a finite sort of
encapsulated universe we're not talking
about a 60 or 70 year continuity so I
agree I would not get life model decoys
or clones or any way of bringing dead
characters back oh I'll make a single
exception for doombots for doombots but
that's it okay yeah so the first thing I
don't want them to do is venom that's my
cheap shot at the Sony's property but it
actually ties into another thing not
just venom the sinister six okay and not
just that I don't want them to go
explore this realm of doing villain
based movies I don't think they need to
I also don't think and you you might
argue doom with me but I don't think
there are any Marvel villains really
that I want to see or deserving of
handling their own movie I like I just
that's that doesn't seem to be the
nature of this movie universally they've
done such a good job of building these
heroes and making them the standard to
the point where most people would say
they have a they're deficient in their
villains in these movies yeah and I
don't think they should be tempted to
like you know counter that by making a
villain based movie I don't want a movie
based on the semester six make them the
villains of the spider-man movie I don't
really want a doctor do movie I want
them to be the villain of a fantastic
four or an Avengers movie like the one
exception that Marvel has or that there
is a model that I could see doing a good
believe would be Dracula but even that
like as much as I love tomb of Dracula
I love the horror corner of Marvel's I
don't want those like bit established
properties I don't really want Dracula
or werewolf by night or monster or
Frankenstein filtering into the Marvel
Cinematic
there's still elements of horror that I
would love to see the play with and you
can use Doctor Strange as your
springboard mat or something else like I
still think they could do blade they
reverse the blade maybe Morbius I would
love to see them do Man Thing but I
don't want them to go because now you
gotta say if you actually bring in
somebody like a Dracula and you're like
so is he the Dracula legend now because
we weren't supposed to be in this more
grounded reality I think that kind of
yeah isn't so but that's so that's a sub
tangent of this whole thing is I don't
want them to make I let you connect up
something else I don't want them to make
a movie basically a villain origin we or
a villain spotlight movie well this
isn't you because the first thing I
think we actually run into is this is
where we run into the issue of the that
the one corner of the Marvel Universe
that marvelous elf does not have direct
control over which is spider-man because
most of what you cited in most of the
ones that haven't been rumored or are in
fact coming out later this year
then I'm sinister six those are so many
joints and this is me saying Sony you're
doing it wrong yes which is fair and
true but you know that that is they are
still at least tangentially connected to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
they'll still bear the Marvel logo on
them even if direct continuity things
are made so I think this is a case where
I'm not sure there's too much of a risk
of Marvel itself actually doing that
they don't seem to be leaning that way
and I'm actually trying to think of how
often even in the comics villains have
been given their own title for more than
like a few issue many I feel like it's
not something that they've really gone
in before excessively as far as doom
goes I would say may I say it would
depend on the director that you got I
would say there is a possible good doom
rise to power movie because I think when
you do him as a villain in Fantastic
Four he already needs to be the ruler
Latveria
I think there might be a movie
to be made in saying how he got there
how my bird would also not be necessary
he doesn't need that either so that's me
saying you could do it but it's I'll
grant it's still probably a better idea
to not I think it would be a tempting
shortcut to make him the next famous
instead of seating him in five three or
five different you know movies as a
villain or as a cameo linking those
different movies building up to that
point if they just want to say you know
the end of face for Doctor Doom is gonna
be this level of threat or something
like that and they wanted to get who he
is across quicker I can see them being
tempted to do a doom solo movie and it
might be good but I would rather them
not yeah yeah I agree with you on that
and yeah and oh yeah I guess not Julie
it's not just some B's problem but I
would also look at what Warner Brothers
is doing with Suicide Squad which but
also like their insistence I'm trying to
do things like Black Adam and Joker as
solo movies and Harley Quinn's getting
our own movie and yep so this next one
this is another one that that I need to
be very clear about what I mean because
otherwise I will have people telling me
in the comments it already exists a
multiverse now when I say multiverse I'm
not talking about what got introduced
and hinted at in Doctor Strange and
ant-man I'm not talking about other
dimensions of completely different
natures from our own I'm not talking
about things like the Dark Dimension I'm
not talking about the quantum burst all
that stuff fine because their realities
totally unlike ours what I'm talking
about is alternate versions of our
reality I'm talking about a different
world where some good guys are bad guys
some bad guys are good guys I'm talking
about you know the the world that's on a
different timeline where you know maybe
it's it's like mid like the 2099
universe is technically a multiverse
stored because otherwise they'd have to
explain exactly how things got there
like that kind of cowboy universe where
they lose a cowboy the cowboy universe
the the
the what is the 1642 universe you know
all these different things that they've
had in marvel over the years and that's
not me saying that these things are bad
because some of them have been quite
enjoyable but the movies do not there's
there is so little to be gained and so
much confusion delay or in it I mean you
want to know how confusing multiverse
stories is how many times has DC blown
up and then rebuild his multiverse over
and over and over again Marvel has never
had to because they kind of do their
other their alternate versions like as a
lark once or twice they don't keep going
back they don't actually integrate them
excessively whereas DC just in the
comics has done that repeatedly and has
to keep getting rid of the multiverse
and then get bored and bring it back and
then get rid of it again and it's it's
messy there's so little to be gained and
so much to lose in terms of audience
cohesion mm-hmm
for clarification how do you feel about
time-travel stories that might kind of
have a like kind of like break the
timeline creating a sort of an alternate
reality or an alternate future all right
let's lump this thing because I had
time-travel it's a separate thing that
they should not be doing let's roll it
all together I don't want them to do to
do time-travel either for basically the
same reason okay and look here's here's
the main reason that I don't want them
to do either of these things it's when
you start integrating those things into
a universe as expansive as they've
already made but is still limited in
many ways by you know these actors are
gonna age out of these parts etc etc I
want them to keep the story moving
forward for as long as possible okay
when you're publishing the comic books
you can do the kind of navel-gazing
continuity focus let's sort of play with
our own history and alternate thing kind
of stuff because you have plenty of time
to undo reset retcon etc the movies we
are on borrowed time because these
actors can't play these roles forever so
I don't want the movies to the
into the Oh what if it had been
different and no just tell me a new
story
don't tell me an alternate time altered
version of a story you already told me
or a version where the Avengers were
were founded by a different character
than the were like Hydra founded the
Avengers late I don't know
move the story forward because I like
these characters on I want to see what's
next for them not a weird scrambled
alternate version of what already
happened
okay I had a reason for asking this
specific question I don't want to
explain why I did because I'm worried
that it'll spoil something like spoil
something you're gonna talk about it a
little later
no no okay okay you can't just I will
just say that ties into rumors all pure
rumors unfounded but rumors that I have
heard about Avengers for well I've heard
enough fan theory about how the Infinity
Gauntlet is going to break reality this
that or the other which I won't be
shocked if they do but I I really don't
want them to I don't want them to go
there find out that next year okay well
then since you're sort of brought up one
of those things that actually was gonna
lead to something the whole idea of like
a different founding or changing the
timeline a few recent developments in
the comics that I really don't like one
of them should come as a surprise that
nobody who has been following the comics
but the recent revelation of the
storyline where the Red Skull used the
Cosmic Cube did basically change history
and make it so that Steve Rogers was
adopted by Hydra when he was a kid yeah
and that they basically made him a Hydra
agent his entire life and throughout the
entirety of Marvel history he has
secretly been an agent of Hydra which
was based on the Nazis Captain America
functionally a Nazi Marvel thought this
would be a great story arc at a time
when because of the movies and because
of Chris Evans's portrayal and just who
the guy is in person and you follow them
on social media I was like he's more
popular than ever let's give up
all the middle fingers in the universe -
that whatever legacy we got there and
just just a one of those ideas that's
like at best this is an interesting one
issue of what if but to make it like
this event then you build up to for a
year and a half it's it's an offensive
story idea and to see it the way they
executed it to make Captain America an
agent of Hydra there's Nazi awful
monster yeah I I never read those
stories so I have no idea how the
execution was my read on them on the
real way that Marvel mishandled that
whole story in the lead up to it was not
so much the idea in and of itself which
is not a great idea but honestly I don't
think they would have had to deal with
as much crap if they hadn't kept
insisting over and over and over again
no we mean it right no this is the story
when I mean ultimate and ultimately
turned out no it's not the real history
because Red Skull used to Cosby Judah
which is the kind of crap everyone was
speculating in the beginning but Marvel
insisting no we're serious this is
really this is the real true history of
Captain America that was where they
really missed depth because that means
one of two things either they think
we're stupid and that they're and that
they think we're gullible and that we're
not gonna call them BS and then we know
they're gonna wreck on it or they really
mean it and they are completely
tone-deaf but V and I hope they started
insisting on that that was not that was
a huge misstep I also think there was a
there was a they were completely
blindsided by how the the amount of
hatred and backlash that came of them
because the writer and one of the
editors may I don't think the
editor-in-chief but one of the senior
editors involved in it they got really
belligerent with a fan base online and
like start attacking people calling them
on is like yeah it just it was the
editor he became the face of a whole
debacle yeah so anyway so yeah stupid
don't do that yeah - something else sort
of relate to that it actually happened
before that with the actors having
contracts that will expire soon
presumably Avengers 4 will be the last
movie with Chris Evans playing Captain
America one way or another he could
choose to read up his contract he could
stick around I don't know
but as much as he is the defining
Captain America I almost I don't like
the idea of an Avengers team without
Captain America it kind of it it feels
somewhat less legitimate like having a
Justice League without Superman or
Batman Steve Rogers has been replaced
several times in the and in the recent
comics and most recently he was replaced
by the Falcon yeah I don't like that
that's not because I'm racist I am very
racist but that has nothing to do people
who don't look like me use that for when
you run for office Nicki gal Vega no
it's the reason I didn't like Falcon
becoming Captain America was because I
really like Falcon as his own character
and he's not a sidekick like Robin or
Kid Flash stepping in to fill his
partner shoes he was his mentor shoes he
was kept partner the Falcon was a
separate identity and it felt like they
were like oh we're giving you a
promotion said he didn't need that Bucky
I think is the logical extension if
you're going to kill off Steve Rogers if
you have somebody fill those shoes it
should be Bucky because he was a psychic
he was the best friend and it's also
it's a compelling story because for
everything and all of the ways that
Steve Rogers represents America at its
best
Bucky represents an America that has to
own the fact that it's done some bad bad
things and it needs to atone it's got a
lot of skeletons in its closet and I
think that is a more compelling story of
having a Bucky feel the weight of this
and having to redeem what he has done so
if you need to all this is to say that
if you're going to kill off Captain
America and have somebody else step up
and carry the shield don't be Sam Wilson
the Falcon I love that you you snuck in
something that is a
should do in this conversation about
things that they shouldn't be alright we
are done but we are not so dumb so this
next one some people who saw our
previous discussion might know this
one's coming Marvel Zombies oh I did
have some bug list but I knew you were
gonna do it oh actually I was surprised
that you didn't bring this up when he
got to the parallel dimensions or luck
or the multiverse well it needs to be a
separate conversation because my issues
with Marvel Zombies in the concept of
doing Marvel Zombies this movies his act
goes way beyond the fact that it would
be an alternate dimension mm-hmm in and
of itself I have problems with this now
let me be clear about something else
first I don't have anything against the
Marvel Zombies property I never got into
it but I know a lot of people love it
and that is fine it is a perfectly fine
thing I'm not saying that it should not
have existed in the first place I am
gonna say that it should never ever ever
ever ever be translated to film for a
number of reasons first of all if you
ever did you would have to do it full
Gore all rated r-rated otherwise what's
the point right but when you when you're
doing it in the comics which again have
a ton of precedent yeah for alternate
versions alternate realities some more
adult some more kid-friendly including
up characters that you know you can have
a more adult version or a more
kid-friendly version of the same
character that's been going on the
comics for so long you can have that
there the movies are a cohesive unified
whole so even if you have it as a
multiverse go oh no it's an alternate
dimension where this is happening you
are still going to have kids who love
these characters even if they don't go
see these movies seeing trailers because
you can't hide trailers from kids where
Captain America tries to rip out the
Falcons throat with his teeth while his
flesh is rotting off his face and I'm
sorry I don't care how much you think
that's cool that's not okay it is not
okay to put that
film in a world where we have made these
heroes be heroes that the entire family
can come and enjoy and this is not me
saying that Marvel can never make
r-rated movies they can but make them
with characters who are already r-rated
characters then it'll probably suck but
you can do him as an r-rated character
that works from the ground up if you
want to do them that way that's fine but
having spider-man get his guts ripped
out that doesn't work and before anyone
quotes Logan at me Logan is different
because Logan was a hair girl you always
knew was being held back by the pg-13
rating in the first place so moving him
to an R rating was a natural progression
and a swan song for him these other
characters that dominate the the
iconography of Marvel Zombies zombie cap
zombie Fantastic Four zombie spider-man
all didn't know these should not be
thrown up on posters in trailers on film
dripping viscera and blood and gore from
their faces that this should not ever
happen no I agree and I maybe I'd sound
prudish by this but I can as they found
the reports of Logan that felt
gratuitous because I remember watching
that movie and thinking as much as I
liked it I think I would have liked it
to be pg-13 now that's I'm sure I'm in
the minority in that on my TV one only
person who actually felt that way and
fine but no I completely agree with you
and I did read the original Marvel
Zombies series and felt that it was
funny at times also a little bit maybe
mean-spirited that's not supposed to be
funny but it's a brand of humor I just
don't need you know and it's all--it's
it was by Robert Kirkman who created the
Walking Dead so I understand the
crossover but I'm not a family of his
writing I'm not a fan of The Walking
Dead yeah I'm just not a zombie fan so
they are all kind of like straight
against it so yeah I agree that's not
something I want to see in these movies
yeah I mean add that was that was kind
of my pick one that so you got any more
like I'm even trying to think like I
mean it would be you're right
scenario but like if we got like in 2020
to a Fantastic Four movie where Reed
Richards and looking at a multiverse and
we basically just for like a fraction of
a second we just didn't go in PSA's of
these different parallel worlds if
there's one that just looks like a
zombie spider-man it's like even that I
don't know I don't really know even as
an Easter Egg II kind of thing I don't
really want to say well not to mention
that's one of those things where you
can't even Easter egg it cuz the instant
you hint at it there are a fair
percentage of fans who will start
clamoring for it it's like when they put
the aliens called the end of predator 2
maybe it was only intended to be a fun
joke but you know what started happening
immediately after everyone clambered
when are we getting alien vs. predator
right obviously I'm just not the
audience for this thing but again I'm
not saying the comics shouldn't exist
you have the comics enjoy the comics
keep them up the screen last time when
we were doing our what DC should do I
think I was wearing a Hawkeye t-shirt
you were cuz I'm a big hawkeye fan I
don't want to see a Hawkeye movie from
the Marvel Cinematic Universe mmm I
don't really think the character
deserves it and this is actually one of
my feeling and it seems too
contradictory as much as I like the
character I don't think he really
deserves much of a solo life in the in
the comics his best moments are as a
member of the Avengers or as the leader
of the West Coast Avengers he had a
miniseries in the eighties it took him
20 years to get his own miniseries and
he had a backup feature recently just
within the last 10 years he had an
ongoing series written by Matt Fraction
with art by David Asia or a really
really good really well regarded great
series but as I was reading I was like
this doesn't feel like Hawkeye to me
this feels like they were writing the
cartoon Archer was that type of humor is
that type of jokes that type of
characterization and they just put a guy
in a t-shirt with a bow and arrow in it
and kind of but wouldn't that still
possibly work as a movie but just not be
the version of Hawkeye that you
personally have the love but I also it's
the version of the the movie version of
Hawkeye is a completely different animal
you know Hawkeye as he was envisioned
was a kind of roguish you know
character he like grew up like like he
was like a circus brat that with his
woman became a criminal but he was also
like once he joined the Avengers he was
a boss hater he was Wolverine before
Wolverine he was always challenging
Authority he got into fights with
Captain America over who should lead
because he thought Captain Urkel is this
old fogey from a different generation
who didn't understand took them years to
come to this grudging respect and then
like over that time he end up becoming
his own leader not a great one but he
was also kind of a player kind of a
womanizer he did eventually get married
but like this version in the you it's
like he's a SHIELD agent he feels very
military clean-cut like he's a company
man he's a company man he's got a wife
and a family and it's like this is a
this is a different character and it's
just kind of like it's and as much as
like I used to think as a black really
wanted this care to shine I'm telling no
I think this Hawkeye is just kind of
taking up here for all the characters
because I don't know because he doesn't
have the costume even though his costume
from the comics is not something that
remains likes to see I looked at Hawkeye
cosplay a bit like yeah I don't think
there's any way of bringing that to the
screen and I just so so let me ask you
this it sounds like you're saying you
kind of wish he wasn't in the movies
anymore either this version are you kind
of secretly crossing your fingers that
he's one of the ones who bites it an
infinity war I'm not hoping for any
doubt so I'm expecting some I'm not
hoping for any because I just like all
the characters but I just unless they
can do something really different with
his character and I'm not talking about
like giving giving him a different idea
like making him Ronin or something it
was just like a ninja and that's I've
like the character in the comics I don't
recognize the character on screen so I
don't think that giving him his own
movie which I've actually I don't think
there's ever been really much of a rumor
maybe people expect if Black Widow gets
her own movie that Hogan
which now I don't even know if I want a
black widow movie because they're making
a black widow they're making the black
movie that I want and it's called red
Samara
yes the black movie though the Black
Widow movie that I wanted know if they
did if they did another one but also
like a Nick Fury movie I don't I don't
care enough about the Sam Jackson
version of Nick Fury to want him as in
his own movie I I'd be I'd be
potentially up for an experiment again
like a full-on proper skullduggery spy
movie because we've gotten bits of that
we had the political thriller stuff
going on with when the soldier we could
do that is after that if he had stayed
on the ground they would have no place
for that except they brought him back in
the next movie in age of Ultron which is
yeah I don't know why they bring him
back for every Avengers movie he there I
think just me I just we didn't really
care about the Phase two movies he just
wrote Ultron the way he wanted to tell
the story I think he ignored most of
what was going on in the previous yeah
probably
sadly I think I have one other but I'm
not sure it's worth guineans yeah I mean
the other thing that I just wanted to
bring up with I'll just say it real
quickly it's not even worth delving into
because it's kind of self-explanatory
just no magical no magical resurrection
no I don't want anyone who dies in
infinity war I don't want their deaths
undone with the gauntlet or the reality
or whichever gem would allow them to
alter the events so that they bring them
back just know like the the fake-out
deaths are already old but I mean that I
do I do make a distinction between a
fake-out death and a magical
resurrection mm-hmm the fake-out deaths
they've had those are already tired they
need to stop
but magical resurrection oh they are
really dead don't worry now they're fine
no no no no which characters have
actually died it so far stayed dead in
the films yeah I'm assuming you mean
aside from villains because remember
right
Quicksilver yeah James Gunn said will
not come
as long as he's in Church of that of the
cosmic okay so that's two if we follow
the premise that we'd both assume that
the movies and the TV shows don't yes
like okay yeah we news will never be
affected by what happens in the TV shows
I mean if you're using that to say
Coulson I still kind of want to say the
different closing back because that
first season of a just filled they were
actually doing crossover it was only the
first season of agents of shield but
they did actually have Samuel Jackson
here on those and I mean he'll never
show up in the movies again but Coulson
yeah yeah Coulson um so I don't I don't
even want to give them him although I
suppose depending on how you wanted to
find even by the rules that I myself
laid out okay maybe Coulson so let's say
two and a half we've had two and a half
permanent hero deaths one one is of an
antihero yeah and yeah these these
characters just don't die we've had
faked out deaths for Nick Fury we've had
repeated fake out deaths for Loki and I
like most of these characters I don't
want to see them done but yeah I don't
either but don't don't jerk me around
don't pretend they're dead when you're
not gonna kill them the only other sort
of they're kind of like question I bring
up relating to once assuming assuming
everything goes fine with the Fox
acquisition yeah and assuming Marvel
Studios does get does get the Reds to
play with x-men and Fantastic Four yep
x-men specifically are there particular
domes that you want from that world or
from that sphere because I was kind of
thinking like looking at some of the
movies that we've already seen like
should Marvel Studios try and do a Dark
Phoenix saga no not for a while because
the the x-men Dark Phoenix movie is
still going to come out and it's going
to be terrible and it's going to be
their second attempt at doing yes or so
I'm not making a blanket statement a
Marvel shouldn't do Dark Phoenix I'm
gonna say the the wells been poisoned
twice now then
to leave it alone I think my big don't
with marvel taking over x-men I had a
whole separate video on this is don't
try and integrate the existing
characters continuity at all
and I know that Hugh Jackman actually
said he'd be willing to come back and do
this again I'm not going to they're not
they're not no well they they wouldn't
because if they're gonna bring in
Wolverine they're gonna want a Wolverine
they can have for ten movies Hugh
Jackman will come in for one maybe two
and again this feeds into the multiverse
thing don't go like oh well these x-men
were in a different universe and like
don't do that so that's that's my big
thing however they choose to introduce
the x-men and introduce mutants it has
to be done fresh it has to it has to
basically ignore at least narrative Lee
ignore everything Fox did maybe have an
eye on what worked and what didn't watch
so that you're not repeating the same
things both positive and negative
because even if you do something right
if five it was one of the things Fox
already did right maybe don't do that
right away which is actually why I say
when they start introducing the x-men
Wolverine needs to be down the line he
should not be part of the initial group
of x-men that they are pushing I think
they need to start with characters who
either weren't in the movies at all or
were background characters and feel like
they never got their proper do I think
they're cool their initial starting core
of x-men characters should be made up of
people like storm beast Nightcrawler
plus Colossus shadow shadow cat those
should be the characters put front and
center Wolverine gene Cyclops magneto
beasts folks need to be put on the back
burner yeah I was it that was one of my
points too when I was thinking about the
question I was thinking I don't want the
movie to be about eggsy i don't want all
of the x-men movies to be about Xavier
philosophy versus Magneto's philosophy
about yeah and the second generation
with this Wolverine and mystique thing I
don't want those dynamics those
characters of Madonna they had ten
movies and they only based about four
characters yeah yeah and and
and I say that as a shame because that
that was a really good dynamic that they
both particularly between professor X
and and Magneto but it was done to death
and I actually want to see magneto
introduce again I did a whole separate
video talking about how I think they
should introduce him yeah
into this universe but I say that while
acknowledging they should still they
should still stick him in in the back
for a while and initially start out with
somebody else as far as their primary
antagonists for the x-men to be having
to deal with I mean start with the
Hellfire Club not e not necessarily
Sebastian Shaw but as an entities you
know start there a proto version of the
Sentinels that aren't like huge because
the government hasn't upped it to that
level yet but they've got way smaller
kind of like hunter killers the Morlocks
I've always liked the idea of the
Morlocks I don't think that's one that
you start with yet I mean that's one
that's one they never really did in the
movies at all but one character that I
was kind of thinking that could cross
over from the Fox version to this would
be Deadpool because of those because
he's fourth wall right so he could not
get a peanut look like what it's like
everything looks different what is this
- I am yeah Deadpool is basically
allowed to be the exception to
everything but the thing is like the
more you look into like the the Disney
and Fox deal which is not finalized like
now that thing might take another year
or two just to get through all the legal
and corporate entity like transfer
everything's like they have to go
through a ton of red tape and paperwork
and everything to finalize that thing
that deal might not be solidified until
the end of 2019 yeah so by then it's
like okay well it had two deadpool
movies they might be in production of a
third one if it's something this one is
good or what they might have plans for a
Deadpool annex or so might Matt what or
need that character to cross over when
the time comes so I mean I think
Deadpool will a be allowed to exist in
his own pocket universe because and but
if they wanted to cross them over they
can because
I guess he by his nature he breaks rules
on he already in his first movie was
already pointing out the inconsistencies
in the casting and the university
already exists in I remember seeing like
some other his other commenters when the
Disney Fox deal was like official like
that it was sort of approved they're
like oh yeah we're gonna see the
Fantastic Four the x-men and Avengers 4
I remember seeing that like do you
people not understand how time works
they already shot Avengers ball that was
so Whitten like impeded people saying
like that Galactus was gonna show up in
something like no people and people are
weird and don't understand time because
you opened the door for x-men coming in
I am now gonna push back on you for the
no villains movies because I would say
there is good mileage to be gotten out
of a Brotherhood of mutants origin movie
with the rise of them paralleling
something like the rise of the Black
Panther Party and their agenda being
this militarized force pushing for a
domestic terrorist group or yes like a
political party yeah I'm sure that
violent showing what push these people
to the degree that they they get pushed
I think you I think that you could get a
movie out of that I would almost rather
see that angle and that interpretation
use just for the x-men because so I
actually radicalize the x-men themselves
yeah because it gives further credence
for why they don't get along with the
Avengers and why the mainstream Marvel
heroes and and the so-called good guys
have reasons to fear and hate them okay
fair enough so I think that'll about
wrap it up yeah I'm done okay so folks
all this stuff that we've gone back and
forth on whatever your thoughts are on
any of it how much of an idiot you think
he is because I obviously I made
flawless arguments drop something down
to the
let's and let's talk about it he's got
all sorts of podcast I'll put a link in
the description down for some of them
maybe one of them at least and as for me
you can support me in all kinds of ways
there's patreon there's swag available
through the patreon plus you know
Twitter podcast like subscribe this
links for all this stuff down below so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]